another trailer for one division has
arrived today you better subscribe and
click that notification bell because you
best bet we're going to be covering one
division on this channel and for those
asking cobra kai reaction should start
going up
tomorrow keep a look out for that anywho
one division new
era trailer let's check it out
i do
ah sword
[Music]
how cool how cool
get a classic tv theme song all right so
these trailers seem to be like a little
bit
expanding upon it seems like every new
trailer is just a little bit extra
more than what we got from the last
trailer there's been a lot of trailers
been a lot of tv spots and yet
still a lot of confusion still a lot of
mumbo jumbo
a lot of crazy reality warping you get a
better look at one of the babies it's
either wicking or speed you get more
looks of their costumes here from all
the shows
i've been doing my research on one
division i'm almost done with house of m
not only that i have started re-watching
i love lucy
so i'm gonna be going through all of the
television shows
to get every single reference possible
that's how much i care about this series
divide and conquer
you watch all the 60s and 50s sitcoms
i'll watch the 70s and 80s sitcoms we'll
both do the 90s and then between us
two we can get every possible cultural
reference
touchstone yeah yeah i really hope you
do that john i love this moment when
they're in there like this magician
costume maybe that is a reference on
bewitched or i dream of genie i don't
know i don't really know the shows that
well then you got that one black guy
pointing at them
and then wanda and paul benny are like
why is that black guy pointing at us
this is the 1950s this is crazy it's not
accepted get out of here get out of here
maybe they've created a more tolerant
little micro verse
racism right that's the true heroism we
can expect from one division moving
forward i'm excited for all like the
spooky creepy horror stuff when that guy
who i'm assuming is from sword is
popping out of there and you know
obviously losing touch with reality
throughout we've talked so much about
wanda vision from the many trailers and
the tv spots i'm just excited this
show's finally coming around the corner
i think it's so cool that marvel is
launching their next phase with the
disney plus series that makes it feel
that much more
like an event plus we'll have a song
that's not
let it go to know these people before
it'll be great and that's really cool
that they got their own original wanda
vision song and it's in the style of
like these classic
televisions sounding tunes as well it
has this like ironic touch to it words
like warm bubbly choir music or
something yeah you know that it's like
everything's all positive and bubbly
but that's only on the outside we know
that something really malevolent is
percolating and
rising up through the ranks like the
actual 50s we'll see
this is going to be an exciting journey
subscribe click that notification bell
what do you think of this one division
trailer
are there more trailers to come my god
it's right around the corner last but
not least
i want to shout out my man eric
horstmann i've been talking so much with
eric you are
undoubtedly our most loyal patron jack
we've ever had you're one of the top
three for sure
the biggest contributor to our live
streams and the more i talk to you the
more i get to know you
the more i realize how much we have in
common you started off as just someone
who i got to know through the patreon
page and i'm so grateful
to enter 2021 calling you a great friend
of mine
so eric i love you buddy and i hope that
this year
is much better than everything we
experienced with last year
say hi to your mother for me get to know
your older brother a tad bit more
most importantly wear the nudie pics
send them my way
you have my instagram i check my dm
every day waiting for the nudie pics to
come in
they haven't come in yet so once you
start coming on the nudie pics
let me know that they've come in from
you coming
it's no eric
you